this is the stakeout our first digital
episode but we ranted about that enough
in the last one I had to watch it online
like an animal not that a lot of people
are watching core originally I guess
weren't used to that like whatever
watching though actually ironically I
the funny thing is in some ways I
actually prefer watching it online not
the issue the issue is not that I have
to watch it online the issue is the way
in which they did it like you know
completely screwed over the show's
creator there's no advertiser we're just
gonna throw this I'm into but we've gone
over that that's the issue I don't mind
having to watch it online so with that
said in this episode we got there on the
lookout for bald eagle glasses as they
usually say look for bald guy with
glasses and maybe it was me and he's in
this place and they're they're staking
it out and he never seems to leave and
they finally figure out he's going to
the spirit world and Cora follows him
and finds the bad guy there who I love
the way he gets rid of bad guy just like
you know it's like Cora one second
grants have disappears throws him all
because back let's talk you just throw
all that time you'll just be wandering
in the pit of lost souls for all
eternity but you me what's going on
share
so Cora whether intelligently or not
intelligently you know sits down listens
to what he has to say and he's most
likely telling the truth he's kind of
like is unintelligent she's just
assuming that her friends have got her
back
yeah and that they don't know where she
yeah so we've got the it turns like he's
pretty much a member of the Red Lotus
League of Shadows which sounds awesome
yeah no I'll say when I heard the term
Red Lotus somebody okay well you know
that do you at the vet school we have
make it even darker it's called it the
Crimson Lotus and which is this
the source broke away from the White
Lotus feeling like you know they kind of
sold out and they became part of the man
and the corporations and stuff and now
the corrupt yeah they're basically like
bending anarchists it seems yeah and so
they're starting their banner kiss yeah
they're Tyler dirty dirty it's and
they're pretty much saying that you know
order comes from no order so everything
should be eradicated and we start over
and that's the natural way we're just
people alone is just like well even you
got am in like the president and all
these people in the earth Queen are
totally corrupt don't you wanna see them
go down and like I swear you can almost
see the thought-bubble in her head for a
second well you know now that you think
about it so yeah and eventually they
they go they tried to his minions or
whatever try to go and get corner again
and both sides could capture but by
different people mock oh and Boleyn
they're captured by you know that the
Red Lotus that we can call them that and
Avatar is kind of suckin right earth
Queen captured Korra and I forget a
Hannibal Lecter yeah Wow somebody rule
34 this no I was like okay the
straightjacket I get but what is she
gonna spit bed or something like most Co
she's an airbender maybe she can whistle
a tornado yeah like I didn't know I just
I don't know but yeah so she's in her
timonium gonna love your suit just kill
the nipples and queen I've been to liver
with a summer breeze and a nice Chianti
so and they're heading off and you know
so um you know named next week
that's all we're done okay um I want to
run this by you cuz I'm curious of year
if you're kind of seeing this too or if
it's just do tell no it's okay so I
actually don't know what the hell you're
gonna ask you know the episodes fine
it's a good episode honestly like all
the episodes they're that they're all
good they're all fine um are you sensing
a bit of a formula
with this season because I'm saying to
myself okay so the bad guys are gonna go
like team avatar's gonna fight them with
some cool bending but nothing like
really that massive you know give the
love of Betty's can indeed and then
they're gonna talk about who they are
and it's gonna be a just chaos rules I
want to rule everything for my crazy
plan and and I'm thinking about this I'm
saying to myself you know everything's
good it's good but there's something I'm
kind of missing strangely enough about
the risks take in in the other seasons
to me it doesn't seem like there's much
risk being taken with this season it
seems very safe it's smart but it's very
safe because they've been trying to keep
her out of trouble this whole season
that's been the major defining aspect of
it I mean if you think about second
season Cora's display you know she does
her thing if you think about season one
it's oh you know we've got this crazy
guy who can take away my powers I'm
gonna have to go kick some ass and then
if she wasn't doing that she was in the
pro-bending thing and kicking ass and on
top of this why do you think this new
work this one is right from the
beginning they're just like oh there's
nasty people out there Cora we need to
send you away and then you know Lin
beifong we need to protect you and
that's literally been what's been going
on sense so that's part of the issue is
I think they've been trying to keep her
out of trouble so it's very much this
little game of kind of cat mouse where
they're trying to figure out the mystery
but it's it's not moving very quickly
but I don't really mind it well and
we're getting closer and kind of to the
end and you having it will we get four
or five that this is something like that
laughing I was thinking about like wow I
lost kind of lost track because it's
been like we're gonna show two episodes
at the time and now it's bringing online
now it's one episode again now it's I
thought but I'm actually not sure what
episode we're on yeah but it's go
probably put it when you edit it
together me like oh that's the episode
but but no I'm sort of watching and
thinking like you know even though the
second season
we had some major issues and it was kind
of a mess and everything there was still
like I said there are these the stomach
remember I really remember I really
remember the new characters they brought
in I really remember a lot of the events
and going to the spirit world and the
giant piece I married anything strong
and starting strong and with this one
it's like I said it's not bad but it's
sort just this one note for the most
part it's like I like the kid that they
brought in and I like seeing when sister
but it's like I second that and like I
remember so many characters from the
first two seasons Oh ones that kept
bringing in you know we didn't see much
it when they when we saw a Zuko and the
dragon like oh my god what is this gonna
be and we haven't really seen much of it
well we're not done yet
yeah I know because I hears that okay
like this is kind of like the big long
breath like we had said second season
it's so much shit it in in first season
had a lot going on then this is almost
like let's take a step back and let the
story you just kind of flow at its own
sort of pace and but I mean I'm trying
to think about it it feels this one
feels more like the second part in a
trilogy season two did not like because
that was the problem
season one felt like a closed story it's
you got a beginning middle end and we're
done because they thought that's all
we're gonna get so season two when it
opened up didn't feel like oh this is
the second part in a long story almost
all I was like wow I guess we'll just
kind of pretend season one didn't really
fully happen cuz now we got to create
three more of these so this feels like
that second middle part that two towers
part of the story where it's not bad but
there's a lot of meandering around and
different characters and even like I'm
just gonna say it Empire Strikes Back is
my favorite of the Star Wars series but
if you think about what happens on the
end yeah
the battle on Hoth and then nothing till
the end I mean there it's pretty much
every characters on the Ronda and Luke
is literally doing push-ups on Dagobah
that is your story well so but it's fine
it totally works and I think this
totally works too I don't have a real
issue with it well I think but with with
Empire and those other ones um the
characters we're constantly learning
more and more about them and with like
with the main characters they sort of
level out and and with the villains -
I'm sorry I'm learning it's like they
look cool and they have cool powers but
I'm like in this one it's like they're
fighting again I was like you know I'm
not that exciting because I don't know
much about the character with the
chicken what aren't I I don't know what
much about third eye I don't know much
about I'm gonna cut yeah they're awesome
no no they look cool they got cool
powers but I don't know anything about
them really I know they're they're
outlaws by like in terms of like and all
of that so what water arms would do it's
like I don't know what she would do you
know III don't know what well they're
the back of this one I I don't know I
didn't have that problem with them on
they eventually revealed it he has so
much personality though well when you
get Steve bloom to do a guy's voice that
kind of dunno I mean and he just he's we
get out - he actually if you would go
like this and that's about it but just
his presence was so strong and they
awesome kabuki man yeah and these people
have great designs but yeah when it
comes to light will okay you know this
you're not talking about I will say this
za here is the interesting character and
that you you are right that may be a
slight flaw which is I'm really
interested in knowing Zaheer's backstory
I did the other three I'm just like I
view them their henchmen I'm like I
don't see them right now at least I mean
maybe we'll get more revealed but I
don't see them as being anything much
more than henchmen but I think they've
decided to go with this mystery of
trying to track these guys down
hmm like if this were the original
avatar you'd have well a you'd have a
story from beginning to end and not this
sort of thing where it's is like a new
story every season so you could have the
time to really develop the backstories
of like the henchmen care yeah
Missoula and hench ladies and so you may
not just feel like they've got the time
or they may just be slammed up against a
wall because Christ only knows when
Nickelodeon's telling them at every
other minute like well I'll do it this
way now do it that way now this way well
what I got tell me so too is that
because I do remember with cor with all
the seasons really of Corinth the middle
has always kind of been the least
interesting part you know is there is
like a master Spence in the first one
there was a lot of the bending
tournaments in the second one there was
a lot of the crime drama not really
connecting to the spirits but they have
such good beginning and closing do all
that was a bit more balanced but quieter
middle act yeah I mean though
you know honestly though I thought the
fight in the metal City was amazing so
that was a really high mark for the
middle of the season like yeah I know
but again I'm thinking like you know
avatar season 2 you know when you had
all those great side characters come in
and it's like you didn't need much but
you just sort of got them you know
actually not the level wanted stuff it's
like yes I got it
not as I'm thinking about it though like
we hit that really great fight in the
previous episode and then in this
episode we got this great cliffhanger I
mean like I'm actually not disappointed
like every episode I think has been
written pretty tight enough to get me to
watch the next one it's I mean like I
said there is I feel bad talking about
because they they're good and they're
fixing a lot of the problems that they
had before but it's almost like like I
said I almost I almost want a little bit
that risk strangely enough I want them
to go to some sort of weird actually I
won't say this obviously we had then
like the second season to me kind of
sucked because of that it just was
throwing everything out there and it
kind of just was messy it's hard to say
well I'd rather have something that
throws the dart the extremes and it's
like yeah it doesn't all work but it's
memorable and you know I'll never forget
it or is it something we're not twice in
a row like we just had that so I don't
want to have it again like I mean you
could take the rear you could take the
risk and you could do it really right I
don't know what these guys are facing
though and trying to write this series
so if you want to argue like oh well
they should've just taken
but if it ended up being as messy as
well I could season wise you'd have
people being like I told you it's gonna
snow with all this stuff we don't know
what's going on behind the scenes so I
mean I'm talking more about just the
product that that's put out I think
honestly it's taken risks it's just done
it really slowly and I don't mind I mean
we've got air benders coming back so
we've still got we have this criminal
who's now an airbender who now we find
out as an anarchist
we've got Cora as a prisoner of the
earth Queen I mean that's supposed to be
an ally you know now she's with them
you've got Bolin and Mach oh you know
trapped by the scrim like honestly you
have a whole new metal city that we've
seen with wind beifong's backstory
fleshed out and wooden beifong's nice
now going off to become an airbender
like when I'm thinking about them like
they actually did a lot of stuff so far
um I was actually the one thing that
they did in this that I was really happy
to see and I'm kind of hoping they'll
tap on more is that you see spirits
again there's fear is flying around like
oh yeah that kind of happened yeah I've
seen it like interacting with Mike
tonight I do say this and I kind of was
yeah it opened with trying to get rid of
the spirits out of the city and solving
that problem I feel like that really did
get pushed yeah I'm kind of like I'm not
gonna lie like this story is good
everything but I'm also sort of saying
like you know what's going on with that
city can and it's so weird cuz I always
I can't go out of the city guys assuming
they're going no but that's where the
spirits are and I'm just like and I
guess what the last season was so
promising this change with the spirits
and to me that's just where more the
meaty stuff is they just reversed it you
know the changes people can airbend and
we have the Red Lotus which is really
the ultimate change because they just
want to enter key so they want the
dissolution of all water that's that's a
big change but if they could time but I
always agree
yeah I agree I don't know why the
spirits have been sidestepped but this
whole series from the beginning though
has been it really sees him one is the
only one so far dad like I'm just like
it has been so it was so tightly written
and just knew exactly what it was for
better or worse I mean I didn't like the
ending obviously but that's ten minutes
of suckin and otherwise I thought really
good show it sets since then just
dragging this out and like give us three
more seasons and all of the it just
seems like they got backed into a corner
and they're like crap that I'm not sure
they had a plan like I think they had
that one season because they're like
well that's probably all we're gonna get
out of these people and now they're just
like now we gotta pull three seasons and
then there may be stipulations involved
you know like oh whoa you have to make
sure that each one is its own closed
nuts story which is the exact opposite
of what the original avatar was yeah so
it's a tough position because yeah I
wonder what this would have been the
head Nickelodeon just literally told
them okay
we liked the original avatar do the same
thing
you got three seasons X number of
episodes tell it however you want and go
I am so curious how that would have
worked out my guess is it would have a
lot of these elements that are here but
it would be way more organized and it
would give at a good pace and like yeah
and like yeah like maybe the climax in
season two would be like the climax of
like the third seasons yeah and it would
make sense because it it just doesn't
make sense to me season two feels like
it should have been a season one season
one feels like it's in some other
universe now pushed away now that we got
season three which is like this kind of
dip this kind of slow-moving middle part
of the story I don't know yeah it's it's
weird yeah it feels like - should have
been one maybe three should have been
two and then one should have been three
it's somewhere yeah it's because I still
I still vote that am on out of all the
villains we've had so far is the most
scary at least on a personal level for
Korra and for the concept of bending
which is the central theme of this whole
universe like I would have done that
last yeah like now I don't know I mean
the season form they may be building up
to something
gonna be like holy shit but from what
I've seen so far I would have saved them
on for last
yeah and that's why government they
couldn't do that cuz that's why I gotta
remind myself to that they have they do
have a whole other season coming up - so
I mean me and I'll be curious to see him
it connects to that season like cuz it's
like this one kind of connects to season
two there's holdover stuff but it's also
like well it's our new thing with new
villains and I'm like are we just gonna
kill these really cool guys we just
found in this season and then go to yet
another set of villains and so we'll
have four villains I look weird avatar
pretty much you had like mostly the one
you've got the fire Lord and then you
know Azula and the but they they're
there from the beginning yeah and then
this one it's a new villain every season
it's like monster in a week or something
I wouldn't mind seeing them do count
like what they're doing the Bioshock
games where they had the you know these
two I mean I know it's like three games
but you know these two different worlds
that really didn't seem to connect
Bioshock 2 sucks yeah I didn't know what
you remember the Bioshock 2 but you know
if I forget Bioshock and then BioShock
Infinite you know it's like okay and
that was kind of like there's one song
whatever and then they had these
spin-off games where they very nicely
tied them together and I'm sure they
didn't think of how these two worlds
would tie together but they nice know
they reckoned that it brilliantly - yeah
exactly and this obviously wasn't the
plan but well play it be nice to see
because they're really good writers it
would be nice to see if they can tie
these all together I think they're
trying but I here's my theory I think
they're trying to do that but I think I
could be totally wrong maybe Walt ugly
but I think at this point they have
written off season 1 that they're just
like okay season 1 is its own like weird
odd like but I think they're trying to
tie at least 2 3 & 4 together that's my
guess but how it ties to season 1 I just
can't think of anything I'm like there
really wasn't much held over hmm from
season 1 so maybe they're just like you
know what we'll ditch referencing really
much of anything from season 1 and just
you know we're gonna try to make 2 3 & 4
connect
ok you know what actually like the Star
Trek movies the original Star Trek 1
when it was all said and done it's like
who gives a fuck about the slow motion
picture like you know Star Trek two
three and four
wrap the controvert ohm all work is kind
of one story to varying degrees of
success but I mean you can tell it's one
story arc and they didn't have that
planned they just kind of went along
with it so I mean maybe they're trying
to do that but yeah but I like I like
this season so far I like it too so far
more than season two the only thing I'm
missing is I do hope the back story
about the first avatar and I loved all
that and the some of the side characters
were great the twins and of course
Varrick still need more farik yes but
but ya know and just to clarify I don't
think this is a fancy than Miami's it is
good um and and we're not even at the
end yet I mean so I it's all of this is
just doing what be logs are doing just
saying our thoughts at the time could
get to the very end and just feel like I
know I get it oh my only crab and it's
our help
even the end of season four maybe I
could go back to season and if you know
us another interesting theme antek shift
if you will have a thematic shift uh if
you think of the villain in part me I'm
losing my voice if you think of the
villain in Avatar
it's a Fire Lord he's he's pretty much
it the only one who had a backstory that
was a little more endearing as a villain
a straight-up villain was probably his
father who thought like what can unite
them all as one nations it'll be fine
but I mean Mark Hamill's Fire Lord that
guy's is like he's just cool yeah yeah
he's just fucked up like he's just
pretty much evil think about all of the
villains in this one even am on a Mons
probably the closest so far - maybe just
evil like kind of a douchebag but they
all have this kind of theme of best
intentions gone awry I I didn't argue a
lot even though he was at them on
wanted to eat boy yeah he wanted to
equalize everything he was raised by an
abusive father he wanted to equalize
everything best intentions gonna ride
the uncle with the spirit world's best
intentions gone awry and now we find out
in I don't know if they planned it from
the beginning or if they're retconning
him but we find out through Zaheer that
the uncle was part of the Red Lotus and
the Red Lotus is about you know anarchy
for the goal of bringing about change in
bringing down corrupt leadership again
best intentions gone awry like that
seems to be the theme of all the
villains in this season versus the
original avatar where it's more about
Zuko and everybody trying to basically
overcome a crazy guy it was more about
the good guys and how they're dealing
with trying to fight evil evil itself
just the most part just seem to be evil
like in the second one wasn't he trying
to like you know bring back the ultimate
bad evil spirit of you know life though
don't ask me to remember the second
season some seem not best intentions in
mind no but I didn't he have some sort
of you know you have to do this because
then we're gonna get a million something
happy burger day don't you guys grab
that back
I thought he I thought he believed that
what he was doing was right there was a
reason in that yeah that I don't remind
yeah I thought he thought it was like a
yin yang thing that by locking up the
dark side you know you basically in your
own way we're creating imbalance and
then it was unfair that ultimately what
he was doing was right he wasn't of
course well maybe he was because now you
have to have the spirits and balance it
you know I don't know I didn't get pure
evil out of mmm oona walk yeah I mean
that there was you're probably right
there was something in there where he's
talking about how this is not
technically evil okay it's evil but it's
kind of needed do you know so yeah you
vote for good
so and there was no evil for good in
mark Hamill's Firelord yeah he was just
a dick it's like I want to kill you all
yeah this is pretty much it like image
have been setting the forest on fire
yeah but I don't know I just found that
really interesting and now I think with
here's revelation it came full survivin
suddenly had like a light bulb over I
like being I'm like oh this is the theme
of all the villains like in this series
so yes it's still it's still good I mean
it is still really good um and like I
said it it's purchased me being
impatient honestly I mean just wait yeah
where it's gonna go um buzz yeah that's
just what these feed logs are and just
saying what we think at the time and
yeah there's still good episodes still
curious where it's gonna go and patience
you must learn to seems like take you go
Yoda off his back like thrombin and just
join like a soccer ball you wouldn't
last long cuz Yoda would then just throw
an x-wing back oh oh you're like it we
will see bitch don't say one last thing
is one advantage to watching it online
which is something I notice cuz I used
to watch a lot of anime online when
you're that close to a monitor if you
have a pretty decent monitor you really
get an even better sense of the artwork
like I was watching it I didn't notice
the bound line and I'm just like uh I
was like really it's not a problem for
me to watch it online I kind of prefer
it that way it's just the way they went
about it but the background art is just
so gorgeous and I kind of just
rediscovered it again when they're
wandering in the desert I'm like oh man
this is pretty
so there's advantages to seeing it
online yeah so that's about it and we'll
just see it the next one take care bye